hurry come with me there's no time to
explain
ah everybody dance I am you from the
future
there's no time to explain follow me -
okay I don't know I'm laughing at his
pain but I am hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to let's play
there's no time to explain
still funny still funny now this this is
an interesting little indie game that
I've played a long time ago well not all
of it but I played it for the first time
a long time ago tell funny funny I
played this on Newgrounds a long time
ago when it was a very early demo and I
kind of forgot about it until recently
remembered and it's actually out as a
full game with two seasons which is kind
of Awesome and you'd wallow oh oh god oh
okay ah missiles hey suck it down ah
bang I gotta shoot the engines okay Wow
all right so this is a really
imaginative little indie game and I like
I like playing these ball ready titles
pop hey hey you stop ow okay I don't
know if I have a health or anything but
it seems to be all right so far it seems
to be very forgiving of the mistakes I
am making like what I did just there I
move my window I have to play this in
windowed mode okay one engine left
unjoin bet I can I can shoot those
missiles out of the sky are they good
hey I got this I got this towel oh there
we go
haha quickly on to the next level
there's no time to explain
we must hurry wait wait whoa hey what
are you whoa hey what are you doing what
you doing there what are you doing oh
you oh wow what the hell I'm I am
fighting you those water pretty bubbles
going on there
suck it out of its mechanical spider of
doom or crab
nope nope nope I don't have a health bar
anything so I don't know what's going on
in terms of beginning it hurt anyway I
remember this being an acceptable game
it is ridiculously fun to play so I
highly recommend it to everyone me from
the future you all right
hello oh no I'm paradox
what the hell what done wait a minute
whoa is that oh come on controls are a
little wonky
okay I can't shoot that up I have a
construction worker now what is going on
in this game but it wants it you seem to
be suffering a lot I don't know why I'm
trying to play oh oh no oh there's gonna
be a tough one
Oh notice oh fudge matters oh my
daughter's oh fudge but uh I can't go
over it yes yes I can
[Music]
haha I got the Hat I don't know I'm
yelling but there's no time to explain
ah wrong direction there's no time to
explain
I don't know I am collecting these hats
either but there's no time to explain
budge ah but I can't I can't be alright
enough about your bones future me huh
then how they got predicament here just
gotta be very careful into the future I
go by what the hell whoa wonder the game
has changed I'm now a football playing
football player
no nail it I like this
[Music]
wait no aw damn it
[Music]
stuff about birding Oh
oh there we go Wow
[Music]
how are y'all do that
a donut right in it did I make it huh I
made that whoa holy crap cut it now
that's just right
[Music]
whoa hello nailed it ah I like this gun
better than yelling I'm guessing it
changes as you go through the game I
didn't know that about this
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
ah
now come on I give you this
come on come on I'm gonna get it there
we go
yeah yeah oh okay haha holy hell oh it's
awesome I really enjoyed that I didn't
have a time I didn't have a chance to
say to commentary there besides raha
because it was just so frickin awesome
seriously this game my objective of this
game is not to do a full let's play of
it it's to give you guys a way no like
this is wrong no vodka oh yeah okay my
idea of this isn't too beautiful let's
play of it is to give you all an idea of
what kind of game is this
and what creative and interesting
gameplay mechanics there can be I just
add that bollocks cuz there are a lot of
really really creative games that don't
give me get the attention that they
deserve like I know this one a lot of
you might know about this but it's still
an indie game that needs to have more
attention because it's ridiculously
awesome
there we go
seriously if you think this looks
awesome just play it for yourself this
game is freakin amazing
not even like this game is incredible
ah ha ha
so bad good this
there's gonna be hard Oh
you probably we're an [ __ ] away
you're me okay yeah no you're you're a
cool guy that deserved the best hey wait
a minute
yeah oh yeah the best give me that do
that nothing much I gotta go through
there ah screw you okay here we go very
gently in a window so I kept clicking
outside the window
[Music]
I know it cares
Oh whoops wrong do the Hat I don't even
know what these hats are for I'm up to
do see I kneel back gently' like a mouse
[Music]
[Music]
I'm good at this another boss bound
sucking down shark come ere SS Easter
Egg Texan I legged what are you judge
what am I doing here
God didn't the future me know that all
this was gonna happen so why did he even
go into the jaws of that thing anyway
how much
marelize yeah oh I gotta hit its tail
alright submit its bottom said I gotta
hit it in the fetus that's what I gotta
do
socket yeah yeah yeah I got here oh
that's for that boat I knew it oh wait
no what I didn't see right I'm in the
water
[ __ ] please don't tell me everything
bombs bombs
Oh Sharktopus oh no not sugar puss
oh holy crap
ha ha ha ok gimme I've just fell into
the water
because I'm a fool to myself miss mate
oh no you got me come on bring him in
Rob oh I keep going right into his
tentacle when he's not even gonna hit me
what's the danger here he's not gonna
hit me he's not gonna get me loser
big deadly loser you wouldn't even do
well in a Japanese porno failure what
the hell
holy crap seriously game guys all right
that that's enough for now because I
just wanted to do this to give you guys
an idea of what the game is because I
like doing these little videos about
these indie games and I do a lot of
horror stuff so it's cool to get these
it's fun to get the other these other
really cool games a chance so I highly
recommend getting this game the link is
in the description below I am going to
keep playing it off screen but I'm not
gonna spoil the rest of the game for you
I want you all to be able to discover
something yourself
oops I died okay so thank you all so
much for watching hope you enjoyed this
video click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
not that bright
now where to go where to go where to go
where to go where to go where to go
where did that man who is dude right
here all of my everything
[Music]